we got the story from CNN you love CNN
don't you
eight month backlash hurt Target sales
they fell for the first time in six
years
yeah I'm trying to say this real quick
this is partly why they're so heavily
coming after Trump their cultural
Endeavors are failing targets quarterly
sales fell for the first time in six
years and it's uh
as as consumers pulled back on
discretionary goods and fierce
right-wing backlash to their pride month
collection Target stock dropped 27
percent over the past year
there's amazing stuff
culturally
the right is winning
it doesn't necessarily I guess at this
point post-liberals you know former
Liberals are now considered right-wing
with uh a song like Richmond north of
Richmond what how many I'm gonna look
this up how many of you 17 million one I
saw seven seven where did you see 17 on
YouTube YouTube
right and then you've got all the
different Twitter videos with 10 million
here
you type in Rich and the song pops up
right away Richmond north of Richmond 16
million views in a week wow 16 million
views in a week 16.6 million views
amazing I'll some dude singing a song
about corrupt government
failed policies and he's just got a
guitar and he's just singing and it's
nailing it sound of Freedom just passed
Indiana Jones on a small budget they
just did a press release Angel Studios
at a press release saying all of their
investors just got a uh 120 return wow
oh that is awesome
makes sense considering it was a 15
million budget that pulled in on 7 170
some odd million dollars
so I think I think that's what the Press
really said a hundred let me let me
quadruple check here I'm not sure if it
was 20 on top
like they put in a hundred and I got
like 120.
this is I don't think that it's I don't
think that it's the right wing that's
winning okay so I'm sorry it's their
original investment plus 20 so they had
a 20 return that's still absolutely
fantastic yeah you go to someone and say
I can get you a 20 return in you know in
two years people are gonna that's really
good
especially uh for producing a good movie
on top of it like a good product so you
can feel good about the money that you
made so while those good things are
happening Bud Light Lost 400 million
dollars and what I think it is is this
the anti-authoritarian movement that's
winning this libertarian movement oh
it's not necessarily the libertarian
party but it's just libertarian cons
conception people are tired of
authoritarian crap like finding out
about the government like all this
crispr I'm not crispr but like oh the
the prism program the Edward Snowden
blue blue open and like just finding
about all this like totalitarian crap
behind the scenes with the CIA and the
NSA and all this junk since 9 11. people
are tired of that and they're pushing
back against the corporate government
collusion this fascist crap I think kova
did it and they call it right wing but
that's a misnomer man it is people that
just do not want a top-down Authority
commanding our lifestyle and covet had a
huge part to play and that it woke
people up they were forced to look at
things
I think uh the coveted lockdowns did it
for a lot of people
they went nuts and they and there's a
viral video going around now from a dude
who participated in the BLM riots saying
that it was one of the stupidest and
cringiest things he's ever done yeah
because now he's been realizing what's
going on the smartest thing I think I've
heard someone say is they say what can
we do how do we win we always sand the
show like engage in culture build
culture share culture and then someone
said something brilliant on Twitter I
think Mike cernovich retweeted it it was
sell them on Twitter and X
convince them to sign up for it that's
the easiest thing to do because you
don't need to say Trump is good you
don't need to say RFK is good you don't
need to save a fake is good you don't
need to say DeSantis is good you need
only say hey you should sign up on
Twitter and we can we can chat and share
memes and then they're like oh okay then
they'll start seeing the retweets
they'll see the news Clips they'll see
Joe Biden say if you don't file the
prosecutor knocking the billion dollars
then they'll see CNN say it never
happened and they'll go what
but I watched that video
that's the thing convince all of your
friends to sign up for x
that's the path x.com
I would like say oh boy it's so fun I
got paid
I got Elon Musk gave me 100 bucks
because I was complaining about stuff
how fun I was thinking we should have on
the show at some point like somebody
that's deep in the Deep State yeah
talk about it there must be somebody
that's like tell us why because you guys
are listening right now why do you think
it's a why is it good why is this I
understand like you don't want terrorism
you don't want Timothy McVeigh to get
unlimited amounts of electricity so that
he does the most giant explode like I
understand that but like what aspect of
like trying to clamp down do you think
is better for our society as a whole I
just I want to know I want to talk about
it I can explain it probably in a
rudimentary way that lacks a lot of
information and I'll explain it like
this
Lil Luke and Roberto don't get along
we go in we separate them and we lock up
Roberto Jr he does not know why we don't
care if he knows why we just want him to
do what we want him to do because we
want eggs
and that's it and we want to be able to
make more of the chickens later on
the chickens are probably sitting there
being like they're coming here and
separating us one chicken's like they're
stealing our children and eating them
and they're like oh here they go with
egg gate again
omelet gate no one's stealing your
babies and eating them that's an insane
conspiracy there chicken
is it my point is
these people in the Deep State they
don't care what you have to say they
don't care what I have to say they care
only that their machine functions in the
way they want to function like a chicken
coop they wake up in the morning there's
fresh eggs they get to eat them in their
mind it's the machine operates they get
big penthouses they get to control
military power power over the world all
over the world and they don't want to
deal with China pushing back on them in
some instances they are working with
China I think the reality is the world
economic Forum Western Powers NATO
Europe and the US found out that uh very
quickly the Chinese Communist method was
preferable so there is a conflict
between the west and China but these wef
Elites and many prominent position
people in the U.S politics would prefer
a Chinese Communist system in the United
States I was just listening James
Lindsay on Josie redheaded Libertarians
uh X space on last Sunday and James was
explaining like it's come to the point
where these terms neo-fascists communist
Neil this don't use the word Neo just
call it communist but even then it's
like when you really ask these guys that
are trying like what do you want your
new government to be there like you know
what I don't even care as long as my son
is on top they don't so it you know it's
Goblin King at this point it's just
people who use power to gain power and
screw everybody else that's why you see
people running into the streets smashing
cars breaking into stores stealing
whatever they want because it's raw
power time yeah and they're afraid of
any institution that would threaten that
like you know the traditional family
unit or nationhood and being proud of
your country and being you know bonded
to your fellow countrymen they're afraid
of those forces so they've sought to
suppress them that's why when you have
someone like naive Kelly or Donald Trump
who is a nationalist figure they yell
fascism at them and try to use every
Force they can to cancel them and to
silence them because they are scared of
those forces because they threaten their
power because a family collected with
other families could be more powerful a
nation can be more powerful than them
and that's that's scary to them what do
you think of naive bouquelli the
president of the hero I think he has
saved his country absolutely I mean he
single-handedly wiped out the most
satanic gangs in the western hemisphere
in one foul swoop and now El Salvador is
becoming a wonderful place to live again
it's a safe place to live businesses are
going there it's incredible what did he
do with the car cartels is that what
they were what did he do like when was
it what I saw like three four weeks ago
that they mobilized like their their
military and like surrounded a bunch of
stuff was that what you're talking about
like in one in one moment he had them
all taken or something yeah they've had
a couple mass operations where they've
gone and got these gangsters
um but yeah he's locked them up and you
know you hear folks in the western media
complain about due process and things
like that but when you have a country
that is so destitute and with such
rampant crime you have to be aggressive
and you have to use force in order to
restore order and he has had the guts to
do that a lot of people don't
so maybe so there you think there are
people in the United States that have
that mentality that they're like we have
to use Force because they think it's
that bad or they're being led to believe
it's that bad I think so yeah I mean I
don't think we're quite at else where El
Salvador was when naibu Kelly you know
took power and cleaned it up but I think
we're certainly getting there and I
think when you don't have order when you
have complete chaos that can you know
lend itself to mob Justice and things
like that and a strong man
um so obviously that's not something
that we necessarily want in this country
but if the right individual does it as
naive has done for El Salvador it can be
you know it can restore order and it can
let your countrymen achieve Prosperity
again had it been chaotic in El Salvador
oh yeah their murder rate was some of
the worst in the western world
and now it's safer than most American
cities within over the course of like a
year yes geez yeah it's incredible like
I said I was hanging out at uh I was at
MGM a couple months ago playing poker of
all things and there was a dude who you
know you when you're there you're
hanging out you're talking to people he
mentioned that uh he was leaving soon
and I was like I was like oh you're
leaving the states and he's like yeah
I'm going to El Salvador and I was like
oh really he's like I'm from there but
my family left but now we're going back
and then I was like oh wow why he's like
oh it got really better really good now
it's safe
crazy people who had left the country to
move the United States now want to go
back also people complain about him
being you know a dictator and things
like that CNN MSNBC all those folks but
he's actually totally wiped out
corruption in his country he's limited
government more than any Republican
president in recent memory he's totally
shrunk you know all of the power that
the legislature was abusing and he's
really kind of just wiped out the swamp
in many ways is he like uh he was
elected and then so do they does he have
a term limit I'm actually not sure
not sure about El Salvador I got that
kind of vibe in New York I didn't wasn't
there in the 80s but in I got to New
York in the early 2000s and by that
point I guess Giuliani had cleaned it up
like it was apparently hell on Earth in
the 80s and then that guy's financially
ruined now yeah it's crazy well they I
just think you know the powers that bee
don't want you to know that you can do
what naibu Kelly did or what Rudy
Giuliani did like we don't have to
accept this decline or this chaos we can
totally reinstitute order we just have
Elites currently that are unwilling to
do it because they have no interest in
that right they love this lawlessness it
lets them kind of do their deep State
work with while no one's noticing and it
oppresses people too right it's
dehumanizing almost to live in these
American cities that are rampant with
crime that are totally deteriorated they
want to keep your spirit down
yeah the you mean the leadership does
yeah yes
yeah because then your life sucks real
life sucks every day like you get on go
down to like the street you go to the
shop and then someone's stealing
everything and you're like oh well I've
got all this money I'm gonna spend it on
this food this guy just took it all for
free do you really like demoralizes you
at a deep level after a little while you
know
yeah yeah you feel like things are
beginning to fall apart yeah and then
you're not you're less willing to like
work for the system and then make that
all work out well it's it's it's it's
also simply this things get so chaotic
people eventually just say for what
reason am I risking my health and safety
for this yep I'm gonna just do my own
thing and they give up they said I would
rather just plug myself back into the
Matrix and eat the steak and ignore all
the problems to think that American
leadership would let that happen just
because like I I want to think that
they're overwhelmed and they can't stop
it or they feel incapable well not that
they want it to happen so that they can
strike with their with their Patriot Act
but but like current leadership wanted
to happen because if you don't want to
go vote then it'd be easier for them to
potentially you know get get their
person they would like in in power and
power if you don't go vote do you think
that the US has like become like a
political autocracy do you feel that way
I I I don't know it's a good question
you mean
I don't know here's a question for you
there's a lot of people who are saying
that we live in a simulation a lot of
these AI guys genuinely believe that we
live in a simulation they've tweeted
about it where they're like base reality
what was the Tweet the guy said base
reality happened only one time and this
is not it or whatever what if
he was wondering if he even existed ever
existed in base reality or whatever
humans destroy the planet with pollution
not like the Matrix with robots but like
let's just say that the world becomes
crap it's garbage there's Mass pollution
you struggle to breathe you're thin and
frail there's no food it's overpopulated
so everybody plugs in to the simulation
where you live this life instead
would you choose to leave this
fake reality of comfort knowing that
real base reality was horrifying and
painful oh
why why would you well are we able to
help base reality from this is the
question about politics in general it's
it's a Sci-Fi analogy for would you
choose to engage in politics what is it
better to be a fisherman than to engage
in the politics of man or whatever that
was uh that was uh from the French
Revolution that was what was his name
the number two guy the French Revolution
better be a poor farmer than to engage
in the politics of man and he's
basically saying just give in he's like
I shouldn't have done he's like if I
could do it all over again I wouldn't
have got involved the reason I disagree
with that mentality is
let's say that we'll use the Sci-Fi
analogy of being in a pod in a matrix
one day all of a sudden you start oh you
start coughing up blood and you're like
what's happening I don't know what's
going on and then all of a sudden you go
blind in one eye and you're like you
start shrieking and screaming and then
in base reality there's a guy
bludgeoning your pod with a with a
mallet screaming and you can't see it
and you can't stop it and you can't do
anything about it that's how I view
politics there are a lot of people like
who cares just ignore it's like yes and
then one day a mob shows up and burns
down your house and you never saw it
coming you're ill prepared for it and
now you have to suffer the consequences
in the worst ways imaginable and uh for
those that were prepared and built a
little bunker with beans or something
they escaped long before it happened or
has a strong Community or a strong
Community but though right those who
prepared for the catastrophe before it
happened are probably going to be okay
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored Members Own only shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time